hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge the challenge where week after
week I discover that I have no sense of
humor because I laugh at the most basic
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the internet and yet here
I am again with another slew of videos
that are supposedly funny so without
further adieu I'm not gonna embarrass
myself and we're gonna get right in to
the funny anyways my broski's I got a
bounce bounce on your boys dick hey
got'em no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
No No
why would that be funny and what world
would that be funny none in nunn world
that's not funny
[Music]
[Applause]
not funny but this equal to uh louisia
can find it
what did we just see what was that what
was that they physically delight in one
another's company he turned around and
he saw a small Jew diddily diddily told
you who was no more than nine she's sad
that the grilled cheese his little tot I
must [ __ ] then he said to the child to
bed hmm uh-huh
yeah someone spend time on that
ah no it's fine
that wasn't funny now that the baby is
in the correct position just open up the
app and tap the burp baby button
[Music]
they are in the initial stages of
teaching bunny rabbits that they will
all die you will both die
these are thrilling time Arthur get out
of the tank you're not I'm literally a
talent what to take I'm literally in the
tank you are not my dad literally tell
major Billy gene I was gonna [ __ ] get
out of the [ __ ]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that a [ __ ] cat hey
don't [ __ ] look at me like that
that's a weird-looking [ __ ] cat MA
yeah there's a stray cat outside
I don't want it starting to fight with
Lucy Lucy it's okay it's okay Lucy don't
worry about it ma
Maud is a weird [ __ ] straight cat
outside it looks it looks like
grandmother [ __ ] thing
hey get the [ __ ] out of here I don't
even know if that's a [ __ ] cat blink
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
give me why did that give me why did
that give me what did that get me
there's a weird gasps [ __ ] no no [ __ ]
super super super super
Oh God why my brain is now realizing
that that's not funny that was not funny
[Music]
[Laughter]
I wanna have sex before I get married
well I guess you just have to be
prepared to die
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay that's enough okay that's enough so
yeah we're gonna call it there ah did
you laughs good job if you did bad job
if you did but oh well I'm over 17 or
whatever so I guess anything's better
than what I've got going on so thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to more stuff like this coming
at you very soon be on the lookout for
it and check out the other try not to
laugh stuff I've done down in the
description or in the suggest videos
over there thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye